[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola que tal buenos dias
tú puedes con eso y más tal parece que
será la frase favorita de mi papá le
escuché probablemente desde que tenía
seis años y hasta horas antes de su
muerte no me gustaba me frustraba era
como si cada vez que la pronunciara se
agregara una carga inmensa y pesada
sobre los de por sí ya múltiples
prejuicios y expectativas que tenía por
el hecho de ser la hija única de una
pareja trabajadora y el primer miembro
de la familia en varias generaciones en
tener acceso a otras posibilidades en la
vida vaya frase sin embargo cuando me
enfrentaba ante un reto ante un nuevo
sueño o ante una decisión por tomar
papas se aseguraba de tomar un momento
para reflexionar y considerar una
perspectiva más amplia de aquello que
estaba deseando en el momento
frecuentemente me cuestionaba cosas y
había cuatro preguntas muy comunes a las
cuales debía responder en esas
situaciones
porque como con qué y quién es esas
preguntas me fueron dando muchas pautas
para que en las diferentes decisiones y
etapas de mi vida haya podido ejercer mi
libertad y mi autonomía mi nombre es ha
narrado ayer pero en la cotidianidad soy
rara cuatro letras que engloban mis
propósitos mis valores mis recursos y
mis redes de apoyo al día de hoy
elementos fundamentales en mi vida mi
llegada a este mundo no fue tan sencilla
lo que en promedio lleva nueve meses a
todos los seres humanos para nacer a mí
me llevó casi diez meses nací después de
un embarazo de casi diez meses de mi
madre cómo fue esto posible no tengo
mucha información al respecto y los
médicos tampoco pudieron dar mucha
información o explicaciones del por qué
ocurrió de esa forma probablemente fue
la primer señal de la vida para entender
que en la vida las cosas las haría a mi
modo y en mi tiempo posteriormente a los
seis años
sufrí el primer desengaño en mi vida un
adulto de belo aquel misterio que se
engloba detrás de aquella fecha que con
tanta ilusión esperan los niños en el 6
de enero es decir el día de reyes
recuerdo haber sentido profundamente una
gran tristeza y un dolor estaba
desconcertada pocas cosas me consolaba
no entendía cómo era posible que aquella
magia y aquella ilusión si hubiera
difuminado ante mí recuerdo muy bien que
en casa mis padres en el intento por
consolarme me invitaron a ver que yo
podía seguir albergando esa magia y esa
ilusión que tenía que era posible
revivir la cara que tuviera un propósito
un sueño o algo por lo que luchar al día
de hoy el 6 de enero sigue siendo una de
mis fechas favoritas
tiempo después vinieron otras
situaciones a las que muy probablemente
tú también te has enfrentado crisis
económicas pérdidas afectivas rupturas
del corazón varias por supuesto y
algunas otras adversidades recuerden muy
bien que a los 13 años decidí que
estudiaría psicología en la udlap
era el sueño más grande que había
albergado hasta ese momento y fue
precisamente aquello lo que comenzó a
darle sentido a mi vida y por primera
vez comencé a vislumbrar qué es lo que
quería hacer y para qué quería servir en
este mundo también fue difícil ver cómo
familiares amigos e incluso mis
profesores cuestionaron si la
inteligencia y la condición social me
alcanzaría para cumplir este sueño fue
difícil ver cómo había pocas apuestas
por mí por mi futuro pero sobre todo por
mi sueño más grande
yo me dediqué cada día a trabajar para
lograr ese sueño eventualmente lo
conseguí
curiosamente en la clase que menos me
gustó de la carrera
aprendí uno de los conceptos que más se
ha abrazado en mi ejercicio profesional
y que considero más relevantes para
incidir en el comportamiento humano la
resiliencia la resiliencia diversos
estudios hablan sobre los orígenes y el
cómo se introdujo esta palabra en
diferentes disciplinas los más de ellos
refieren que es un término de la
metalurgia donde se habla de qué es esa
capacidad de los metales para resistir a
fuerzas extremas otras disciplinas como
la medicina y demás también han
utilizado este término en procesos de
recuperación o para explicar cómo es que
nuestro organismo puede sanarse en las
ciencias sociales y particularmente en
la psicología la resiliencia podemos
verla como la flexibilidad adaptativa
que tenemos los seres humanos como esa
capacidad que tenemos de sobreponernos a
las adversidades
muchos dicen que es un proceso otros que
es una habilidad que depende de factores
internos de factores externos que es
algo que todos tenemos pero que tenemos
que desarrollar etcétera los más de los
estudios también refieren que es a
partir de situaciones extremas tales
como desastres naturales cualquier otro
tipo de pérdida catastrófica muertes
significativas pobreza extrema violencia
intrafamiliar que se puede desarrollar
la resiliencia sin embargo actualmente
este concepto ha sido adoptado en la
psicología también para hablar de cómo
en el día a día y en la cotidianidad los
seres humanos vamos superando retos y
sobre poniéndonos a las adversidades eso
puede ser la resiliencia como tal de
forma muy particular considero que
fortaleza y resiliencia no son sinónimos
porque fortaleza tiene más que ver con
resistir con aguantar como cuando no hay
muchas más alternativas y no considero
que algo o alguien pueda sobrevivir en
estas condiciones o puede aguantar así
por mucho tiempo hasta donde yo sé hasta
las maravillas del mundo han sido
erosionadas sin embargo la resiliencia
es un proceso más rico más nutritivo
para los seres humanos y el aprendizaje
las enseñanzas las habilidades y las
fortalezas que deja el sobreponerse a
una adversidad es aquello que se queda
con los seres humanos por mucho tiempo
eso para mí es la resiliencia
eventualmente cuando fui estudiando
cuando fui encontrando aquello a lo que
me quería dedicar ya como profesionista
encontré que la resiliencia es un
concepto importante a desarrollar a
despertar pero sobre todo también a
cultivar en todos nosotros cómo podemos
hacerlo es aquí cuando las preguntas que
mi padre siempre hacía comenzaron a
cobrar sentido
porque es aquello que te levanta que es
aquello que te mueve cada día qué es
aquello que le da sentido a tu vida
cuáles son esos vacíos que desde tu
carrera profesional o desde tu ocupación
observas puedes echar como un vistazo
atrás y observar que soñabas del niño
que quería ser que soñabas con hacer eso
puede darte pistas para encontrar tu
propósito de igual forma puedes ver que
es aquella causa que afecta a tanta
gente a tu alrededor y que si en tus
manos estaría tú podrías resolverla o
que trabajaría para hacer esto o que
probablemente ya trabajas si tienes
iniciativas para
aquello que te impulsa aquello que te
deja paz y que te deja satisfacción ese
sería tu porqué posteriormente vienen
los recursos que son los recursos
aquello que tienes para echar mano de
las situaciones puede ser algo material
puede ser tu dinero puede ser algo que
creas algo que está muy en ti que es de
la piel para adentro pero que tú posees
y que te mueve ese será tú con que como
tal y cualquier cosa que tú consideres
un recurso te puede ayudar y luego
vienen las redes de apoyo las redes de
apoyo son esas personas con las que
probablemente hoy has compartido tus
momentos más significativos en la vida
pero queda igualmente pero que
igualmente pueden apoyarte en tus
adversidades y nos la idea aquí yo
considero que hay una familia que
también se elige con el corazón es esa
gente que te ha acompañado en las
diferentes etapas de tu vida y a través
de los cuales también has crecido ya se
ha evolucionado
tu pareja tus amigos tus profesores tus
compañeros de trabajo gente que te
inspira alguien que ves por ahí en tus
redes sociales puede ser porque no puede
ser una red de apoyo son esas personas
que nos dan amor que nos dan confianza y
que no importa la ubicación geográfica
tu mejor amiga puede estar al otro lado
del mundo y aún en ese uso horario puede
sentir que está cerca de ti y te sigue
acompañando acercarnos a estas personas
en los momentos adversos es como volver
a un lugar seguro y cálido en el cual
encontrarás la confianza el cobijo y el
soporte para seguir adelante y es que
tal parece que cuando experimentamos un
problema solo vemos lo que tenemos aquí
y entonces te dejas llevar por esa
adversidad por esa dificultad te
derrumba te vulnera eso es lo que hacen
las adversidades como tal no obstante
que ocurre cuando levantas tu rostro
puedes ampliar la perspectiva y te das
cuenta que por aquí hay recursos
que por aquí hay redes de apoyo y que
inclusive puedes echar memoria de
experiencias pasadas y otras
dificultades que ya hayas vencido que
hayas
resuelto como tal el simple hecho de
recordarlas te puede dar esperanza y un
empuje para seguir adelante
cuando estamos en una situación adversa
experimentamos un sinfín de emociones y
de sentimientos la tristeza el más común
de ellos y la tristeza en nuestra
sociedad desafortunadamente es vista
como un estado de vulnerabilidad
la expresión que frecuentemente hacemos
de una persona que está triste es
pobrecito sin embargo te invito a que
resignifica es la tristeza te invito a
que la veas como un proceso un momento
una etapa y la experiencia más sanadora
y reparadora que podamos experimentar
los seres humanos es desde la tristeza
desde donde podemos hacer una pausa y
podemos replantear y eventualmente así
es como te vas sobreponiendo escucha tus
emociones escucha tus sentimientos ellos
son una guía ellos han estado ahí
contigo y te pueden orientar hacia dónde
o por dónde puedes comenzar a
reestructurarse no eres fuerte porque no
hay más opción eres fuerte porque tienes
mucho de donde echar fuerza y de dónde
salir adelante en la medida en la que
aprendas a identificar tu propósito
tus recursos tus redes de apoyo es decir
tú porque vas a poder encontrar
y así eventualmente irás venciendo las
adversidades como tal hoy entiendo
entonces
que aquella frase de tú puedes con eso y
más
era la forma en la que amorosamente mi
padre estaba intentando volverme
resiliente no estoy segura de que lo
hubiera conocido el concepto ni mucho
menos de que sabía qué era lo que estaba
yo haciendo sin embargo si considero que
eso me dio las herramientas y la
conciencia suficiente para aprender a
identificar de dónde puedo apoyarme en
quiénes puedo apoyarme y hacia dónde voy
porque estoy convencida que en la medida
en la que aprendas que tus
circunstancias no tienen por qué
determinar tu actitud en la medida en la
que encuentres un por qué vas a
encontrar un como una vez que hayas
entendido que tus vulnerabilidades no
tienen que pasar por encima de tu
voluntad y que ésta debe ser más fuerte
podrás construir tu resiliencia y así de
esa forma
eventualmente serás inquebrantable
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]